now here's the weird thing now cuz Ricky
you've met Matt before haven't you
um yeah he won't remember this it was
only about a month and a half ago - oh
well I thought this was years ago now is
very very rural
I'm still on a bit of a high from it do
you remember nope
but um there's a photograph there's
photographic evidence um I saw on my
Twitter and I if you look at the
photograph you can see saw horizontal
pants on in the photo you can see
someone's a lot happier to be in that
photograph than someone else in the
photograph oh I hear you eighty two
weeks I'm contractually obliged to ask
you about the voice yeah em are you got
a picture of the picture me me in my oh
do we have the picture I'd love it if
you did
no never happened yeah somebody
somebody's on now scrolling to Twitter
so we'll keep talking reminder no so
we'll drive by the picture but err so
the voice yeah you come back for voice
ooh I haven't been asked yet I'm not
sure who has been asked but I think it
probably depends on the other people on
them but Misbah Noga said she no come
back you know come back uh which I'm
upset about who else was on it here it
was me Sir Tom Jones
oh yeah um Kylie and will.i.am weird I
was definitely
a little bit like today I was definitely
the least famous person to that
particular part and and that's the way I
like it
oh stop it come on I know it's the way
lies you know never be the most famous
person up high you're at the wrong party
and I have found out something are we
finding it oh they'll never get it okay
are we told to get on with it they find
it we'll find it it's a great photograph
a woolly hat and you're wearing a Mac
Mac Mac what's a Mac okay what is it
like a lot of talk right
double-breasted raincoat oh hey actually
I think we can see the picture yes this
is this is the - yeah
that's is the spectrum of happiness
with no mattress in the back pissed off
your the welcome beautifu 9 it was an
element of invasion of personal spaces
there's there is a slight whiff I've
smelled a fart
looks like you smelled a great farm yeah
great guys aren't smell the same fart
this is you and James Franco recreating
that shot-for-shot chopper TT good yeah
close your eyes and let the word paint a
thousand pictures
compete see when you when you forget
your line you kind of go and then you
continue